yeah we're just talking today about a
lot of content is like people are are
creating like Christian content like
there's pure flicks which is starting to
ramp up their Hallmark has their own
daily wire flicks I never heard yeah
since 2005. but people don't want to be
bashed over their head with it so you've
got to figure out what's the next phase
and I think the next phase is sci-fi
that takes into account like the
cosmology and this new physics where
we're finding like Cosmic microwave
background radiation that kind of looks
like neurons in the brain and you're
like wow maybe there is a God and if you
can kind of take people in that
direction you know you can kind of bring
God into the conversation and kind of
ground it in like morality but still
have cool sci-fi message on top of that
I mean the whole thing kind of depresses
me
um because I remember there was a time
where there it wasn't like right content
or left content you know it was content
like a movie or a show or whatever you
know was about you know whatever the
topic of the day was or